a viral controversy yesterday uh erupted
on social media as a former NFL running
back by the name of Rashard
mendenhal tweeted something extremely
racist he tweeted I'm sick of average
white guys commenting on football y'all
not even good at football can we please
replace the Pro Bowl with an all black
versus allwhite Bowl so these cats can
stop trying to teach me who's good at
football I'm better than your
goat um I think he means goat like
greatest of all time
an actual goat on a farm although he did
not he rode in in the lower case so I
don't know now again obviously very
racist uh it's also funny coming from
this guy like he's complaining about
average white guys but during his NFL
career he was the epitome of average he
played for six years which is like and
then he washed out of the league which
is pretty average um yards per carry for
his career was less than four about 3.9
yards per carry very average
he had like maybe one or two good years
and the rest were unremarkable and
um and that's you know and it's like it
all equals out to very average he's best
known for fumbling the ball in the Super
Bowl uh costing the team the game
costing his team the game Steelers and
it was a fumble that was caused by a hit
from a White Defender so I don't know if
that's maybe where all this animosity is
coming from I don't know and it is also
worrying when you see tweets like this
like it's worrying to see just how open
and casual people are with their
anti-white racism these days like it's
getting worse over time that's all by
design of
course and that that's really the
headline here if there is a headline to
be found in some washed up former NFL
player being racist that's the headline
with that said though since he brought
up the subject I have to
say and and like many others you know I
was kind of I was actually thinking
about this and um an all black versus
allh game would be kind of interesting
and you know I think our roster would be
much more impressive than most people
seem to think I kind of like our Squad I
gotta be honest like I kind of like it I
mean you know starting quarterback we
got Josh
Allen um obviously running backs
Christian mcaffry is probably going to
be the MVP or should be the MVP is the
best running back in the league so
already we've got Allen and mcaffry back
there so the whites are doing pretty
well as far as that goes the old line is
no problem can easily fill that out uh
you get out and then you get to tight
end the tight end position and it's just
it's an embarrassment of riches I mean
KD Kelsey Mark Andrews if he's healthy
uh hackinson leap pora so we're going to
run three and four tight end sets all
game and uh we're a little more thin at
the wide receiver position Cooper cup
though we're GNA have him there um and
we'll be compensating though with a lot
of tight ends we'll also have Christian
mcaffry running routes out of the back
field so I think we're in pretty good
shape and you flip it to the other side
of the ball I think the front seven of
the all-white Squad is uh is going to be
good we're we're in real good shape with
the pass rush because we'll have the
Bosa Brothers watt
Crosby um so we're getting to the
quarterback all day long on the white
Squad the big issue obviously is going
to be on the back end like the defensive
backfield there
are and I check just to make sure there
are no white cornerbacks in the league
at all like they don't they don't exist
uh I think the last one was in like
might Jason seahorn in like 2002 or
something it's been a long time so we're
going to have to get creative in the
back field um find some guys on a
practice squad throw some linebackers
back in
coverage um you know and we're gonna
have to get to the quarterback is what
we're going to have to do you just not
we're not it's like he's gonna have to
get rid of the ball quickly because
we're gonna have to get to the
quarterback put a lot of pressure on him
but keep in mind something else
Championship squad has to be great in
all three phases defense offense special
teams and
and I think uh the white squad's doing
well on special teams like we've got so
the whites we don't have any
quarterbacks black Squad you have no
kickers so you're in trouble you got no
field goal kickers you got no punters we
got all that we got kickers and punter
punters all day so black Squad gets into
a situation where they got you know
where they're deep in their own in their
own uh on their own side of the field
and they got a you know it's Fourth and
and 10 or something what are they going
to do they can't punt so they're going
to be in they're going to be in in four
down Terr the entire game maybe that
works in their favor maybe it doesn't
I'm looking at a high-scoring game I
think it's probably 47 to
40 who has the 47 I think it could kind
of go either way I've got a holiday gift
idea that's sure to make you the hero of
the season now we all know the holidays
can be a bit hectic the shopping the
cooking the never- ending list of things
to do but fear not because I've
discovered a gift that's not just
thoughtful it's downright transformative
the gift of genell skincare from now
until Christmas genell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
my listeners at genucell.com
/wy treat yourself and your loved ones
to the absolute best skincare in the
world those troubling forehead wrinkles
Fine Lines skin redness and yes even a
sagging jawline will disappear right
before your eyes with genus cell's most
popular collection Jus cell promises
immediate effects you'll see results in
less than 12 hours guaranteed or your
money back jell sent down a ton of
products for the entire office I can't
even put into words how much better
their faces look because of genus cell
everyone discusss me a little bit less
now it's like Christmas came early well
you deserve to also look and feel your
best this holiday season go to jys
cell.com Walsh YT to get this incredible
holiday discount every order now is
instantly upgraded to free express
shipping that's Jus cell.com Walsh YT
there are some question marks here
though like um what do you do about
Pacific
Islanders uh there's like one Asian guy
in the NFL he's a kicker also uh where
do you put them I think probably they
they just can't play I think we have to
just exclude them
um and so it could be a bonding moment
for the black and white squads because
like they're going to come together to
discriminate against these other two
groups which that doesn't happen very
often so you know there's that
opportunity there I think we got just
they they just you know for this game I
think like it's not fair to put them on
either side so they're not going to be
involved um real interesting question is
the biracial players like what do you do
about Patrick Mahomes biracial both
teams are going to want him what do you
do about that I think the fairest
thing is is whatever race the player's
mother is is what team they're on so
white mom means you're on white team
black mom means they're on the black
team which I think means that that the
white Squad gets Patrick Mahomes I'm
pretty sure and here's the best part of
all that coming off the bench for the
white team could be Colin
Kaepernick um now I wouldn't want him to
throw the ball at all because he sucks
but I just wanted to have one snap on
the white team just because that'd be
hilarious and it' make the whole thing
worth it
and you imagine a situ that's the Rudy
that's the Rudy moment that's the twist
ending imagine the white Squad wins in
the racial
scrimmage and Colin Kaepernick is
carried out triumphantly on the
shoulders of the white team' be a lot of
fun you have to you have to admit so
Rashad medal is uh is uh a terrible
racist but at the same
time it's not the worst idea in the
world let's just be honest if You' like
to see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed